if you have somebody in a leadership
position who who literally doesn't
respect
uh uh diversity and and inclusion um you
know the question is why are they in a
leadership position um uh uh so it's
it's a bit of a loaded question now i
understand the challenges you know if
you do things with intention if there's
an intention to go out and find
something you know you're more likely to
find it and i also think what what
companies with resources can do is build
their own bench which is go to
universities you know
invest in the programs that will train
the people train uh in this case as you
said some gender diversity so that they
have the skills and then uh and offer
them the potential for jobs when they
come through the program so you set them
up in other words build your own bench
because i've heard this from companies
before which is you know we'd love to
but the talent's not there you know so
go build the bench if you have a
long-term approach to this stuff it's
not about solving a problem in a month
you know it's about solving a problem um
so that it's sticky so it's not just a
reaction but rather it becomes
inculcated and built in into the fabric
of the company um and and i go back to
leadership training again um which is
what what good leaders recognize is that
a diverse workforce brings diversity of
points of view if everybody looks like
me went to a similar school as me you
know uh was was brought up like me um
then we're all gonna have kind of
similar uh points of view on some of the
challenges we face but when we have
people with different racial um
backgrounds or different or different
genders we you know some people who grew
up in europe versus america or rich
versus poor they bring entirely new
perspectives based on their world view
to a problem and the more diverse
perspectives we have on any challenge it
means the more options we have to solve
that problem um and this is not
surprising to me that when you say we
have a more when we have more diversity
we're actually better at the thing we're
trying to do that makes perfect perfect
sense and so i think one of the things
to do is for senior management to to
hammer away that this is essential for
us it's important for us um and that uh
that leaders are going to be expected to
embrace this
um
that we're gonna be judging our leaders
and their ability to do this to build
um uh more diverse teams and to go out
into the marketplace to before before
these some of these young people start
looking for jobs and start training them
in the skills that you want um and
setting them up it goes to what we said
before which is we want to make you a
whole person we'll give you some of the
technical skills and some of the human
skills and then when you join us you're
going to be a better prepared
a person a better prepared employee to
join to join our team because we've
already set you up for success with hard
skills and human skills